mike tyson and roy jones jr they're
actually they're gonna box each other in
an eight-round
exhibition fight it's pretty cool and
apparently according to andy foster
he's saying that they both agreed not to
try to knock each other out
but i mean can you imagine these two
going at it and not trying to like
actually
one-up each other i have no idea what's
gonna happen
i i i literally i don't know i i don't
know
it's pretty crazy right at least they're
both professionals and they're sort of
the same age
um i don't know horrified sparring match
i guess yeah um
but i mean then if nobody's gonna get
knocked out i guess what i mean
i guess i'll watch imagine you were to
like uh fight someone
in an exhibition match i'm sure if
someone like threw a harder punch you're
gonna try to throw a harder punch it'll
just go crazy right yeah yeah
you guys like that tyson is way more
chill these days don't they
oh man i saw him in a uh talking about
the fights he's just
he goes like this side of me that has
his ego the side of me this not he
doesn't watch that
clip or no i believe it i mean roy jones
last time you know he got dealt with in
russia
he did oh that's his last fight he got
knocked out and then
then following week was on a broadcast
on hbo he's like what are you doing
let me play this trailer for you real
quick what we're not born to be humble
we want to be humble
you can still throw man boxing's a
brutal sport
he dominated dominated
his legs are huge his thighs are huge
his arms are huge
his neck is huge so it's like it's very
risky yes
but guys in control of all cause i was
beating everybody in every weekly as i
was in
what you're gonna do it's like david and
goliath
he's a giant monster we know and my
eagles
man i'm saying you think you fly you
ain't [ __ ] look
the ammo getting here kick your ass you
better get on top of your game you want
to get embarrassed in front of these
people and i'm little david who on the
head
of my side is definitely more talented
way more time and watch what i'm gonna
do
holy [ __ ] i'm kind of excited i have no
desire to let you i do
tyson's still strong enough to knock you
[ __ ] to death so
i definitely want to watch it i think i
think it's been a [ __ ] show
i think people would be really
disappointed it's just like bad would
you pay to watch a sparring match
and they both don't want to embarrass
you how much would you pay for this one
is it pay for
not what if it's not a sparring match
what if it really does either one's
going to sign up to
and the other one's going to allow them
knock them out it's not going to happen
that's why that's why they chose this
opponent
so they just said the deal is don't
knock each other out and they said they
wouldn't they're also they're both
54 years old dude 51 54.
i just i have no desire to see it man i
kind of do
i kind of do would you pay 60 bucks for
it though 60.
i'm not saying that's how much it is i'm
just wondering that's how pay-per-views
are like 60-ish
it's a larger question yeah i feel like
they should pay me be fun to just
do it it's a good get-together as long
as they don't try to kill each other
then fine listen during quarantine i
i'll watch two praying mantis go at it
so i'll i mean i'll probably pay for it
i'll do it gotta do it
all right guys i'm like foaming at the
mouth for it though i'm gonna tell you
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected